[Musique]
bonsoir l'assassinat d'une femme
parlementaire en France Yan Pia député
udfpr du Var a été tué hier soir à hier
par deux hommes à moto la libération de
puchist à Moscou rutcoy et ses camarades
qui avaient tenté de renverser Yeltsin
sont sortis de prison aux grandes dames
de yelsin le choc au Proche Orient après
le massacre d'ébron Bill Clinton et
François tente de relancer les
négociations de paix réflexion sur
l'emploi la convention du parti
socialiste notre invité nous dira si le
parti a des idées bonsoir Laurent fablus
bonsoir La manife des chasseurs dans la
ville de Bordeaux ils veulent pouvoir
chasser en toute tranquillité enfin une
petite éclaircie tricolore dans le ciel
de lilameur médaille de bronze pour le
relais homme biathelon nous allons nous
rendre maintenant dans le Var pour
tenter de reconstituer les circonstance
du drame qui s'est produit hier soir à
hier une femme est tombée sous les
balles de deux tueurs tueurs
professionnels c'est cette femme c'était
Yan Pia député udfpr du Var Patrice
Velet Christophe
vigal quelques minutes après le drame le
mond des oiseaux cernés par la police
vers 20h hier soir sur cette route
étroite Yan Pia rentré chez elle au côté
de son chauffeur deux hommes à moto ont
eu raison de sa vie en quelques secondes
selon un scénario partiellement
reconstitué ce soir sur la petite route
la voiture du député roule forcément à
faible allure la moto des tueur se place
alors à hauteur de la vitre avant gauche
leur objectif blesserit le chauffeur et
immobilisit ainsi le véhicule Yan Pia
sera ensuite touché de deux balles de
gros calibre elle est morte sur le cou
seul témoignage visuel celui du
chauffeur bien que blessé il a pu
conduire la voiture à la caserne des
pompier la plus proche l'enquête a donc
débuté quasi immédiatement après le
meurtre dans la nuit a été retrouvée la
moto du crime une 750 Yamaha volé à hier
très récemment d'autre part une balle
retrouvée dans les vêtements de la
victime fait le l'objet d'une expertise
une enquête difficile pour un crime sans
revendication un contrat selon le
procureur non seulement par le le la
façon d'opérer hier de deux tueurs à
moto tendant un guetapan mais ensuite la
façon dont la motocyclette a été
détruitite marque un souci de prendre
des précautions pour faire disparaître
des indices qui indique que l'on a
affaire à des gens qui ne sont pas autre
chose que les professionnels l'enquête
va se poursuivre plusieurs jours selon
la procédure du flagrantl
ensuite seulement un juge devrait être
saisi du
dossier pour quelle raison a-t-elle été
tuée on ne sait pas pas encore les
enquêteurs restent même prudents et ne
veulent négliger aucune piste reportage
d'Éric lemçon Thierry curté Alain
rabéchot un jour la mère de famille
serait peut-être devenue maire de la
ville un sondage privé récent de N Yan
Pia vainqueur devant les autres
prétendants de la droite elle était
décidée dit-on à se porter candidate au
prochaine municipal et selon ses proches
c'est bien nos regard du contexte
politique local qu'il faut examiner les
menaces qui pesaient sur Yan Pia auteur
d'un livre blanc sur la toxicomanie
cosignataire du rapport sur la dérive
mafieuse Yan Pia avait une ambition pour
hier débarrasser la ville du banditisme
et de l'influence du milieu jusqu'à
présent je que je sache je nai pas
d'exemple de parlementaire qui ét
assassiné parce qu'ils ont fait un
rapport sur sur un sujet quel qu'il soit
donc après il reste peut-être quand même
cette piste là c'est difficile à dire il
reste la piste peut-être que c'est une
personne qui politiquement avait un
grand avenir devant elle à hier la
dernière campagne électorale avait été
houleuse législative 93 la droite ici
est on ne peut plus diviser le principal
adversaire de Yan Pia est un autre
apparenté pr Joseph surcia le climat
politique quand même ici il est plus que
tendu depuis longtemps je peux pas dire
qu' on peut pas dire qu'il est tendu on
peut dire comme dans tout il y a
des des gens qui estiment avoir une
place et qui se se battent pour défendre
des idées qui qui sont les nôtres et il
est on peut pas dire qu' est tendu il
est pas plus tendu que dans la région
parisienne ou ailleurs et pourtant Yan
Pia avait fait l'objet de menac précise
un engin explosif avait endommagé sa
permanence bref l'influence grandissante
de cette femme pouvait gêner il y a un
mois encore règlement de compte entre
Truant sur le port Yan Pia appelle la
ville à réagir un contrat du milieu lié
ou non à la politique ce n'est pourtant
qu'une hypothèse parmi d'autres
vengeance personnelle affaire leuse le
SRPJ de Marseille qui a perquisitionné
au domicile et dans les bureaux de
yanpia ne néglige aucune
piste Yan Pia s'était fait connaître en
adhérant au Front national Jean-Marie Le
Pen était son parrain Yan Pia s'était
distingué en claquant la porte du parti
d'extrême droite son portrait par
Véronique Saint-Olive Yan Pia est arrivé
à l'Assemblée nationale en 86 avec une
double étiquette affective et politique
filleule de Jean-Marie Le Pen membre du
Front national mais de l'intérieur du
parti d'extrême droite y s'oppose vite
aux thèses le pénis elle refuse de voter
sur ordre et s'indigne du calembour du
Rafour crématoire alors il n'y a plus de
filloles qui tiennent Yan Pia est exclu
son engagement politique bascule
entraîné par une amitié brisée
Jean-Marie Le Pen en partant de valeurs
qui sont pour moi fondamental comme par
exemple la grandeur l'honneur la dignité
d'un pays pour ne prendre que celle-là
les ramène à des à des valeurs
restrictives euh à des à des réflexes
archaïques qui font qu'en fait par par
démagogie ou par ça ça n'était pas la le
sens de ce que moi je pense qui est bon
pour pour le pays j'aimis Jean-Marie
j'ai détesté Le Pen en faisant de la
politique avec lui alors à l'époque elle
assume et siège à l'Assemblée sur les
bancs des nonincrits mais en 89 Yan Pia
retrouve une famille au parti
républicain elle emporte sous ses
couleurs le siège de La Valette dans le
Var ces derniers mois Yan Pia avait
beaucoup travaillé dans la commission
d'Aubert sur la mafia et la corruption
et publié un livre blanc sur la drogue
elle souhaitait en faire son cheval de
bataille pour les prochaines municipales
à hier Yan Pier avit 44 ans elle laisse
deux filles et derrière sa mort si
brutale un immense point
d'interrogation Valérie giscardestin
Jacques Chirac François Léotard Gérard
Longuet Charles Millon ont dit leur
émotion et leur indignation d'autres
hommes politiques se sont exprimés
aujourd'hui pour apporter les derniers
propos de Yan Pia elle se sentait
menacée témoignage recueilli par Antoine
Cormery n voulons savoir pourquoi elle
est morte aujourd'hui c'est quand même
la première
femme politique française à être
assassinée dans notre pays c'est un
signe très inquiétant pour notre
démocratie et pour nos
institutions nous sommes l'Italie çaz ça
commence comme
ça député qui se bat avec
conviction contre la drogue contre la
corruption contre la mafia dans sa
région et qui m'avait dit effectivement
il y a quelques semaines je suis menacé
je me sens menacé et je peux même vous
dire que que elle recevait chez elle des
petits cercueils au nom de ses enfants
j'ai l'impression bien qu'elle ne le
disait pas au téléphone mais elle le
disait au cours de quand ell sont pré
qu'elle était quand même malgré tout
menacée et me donnant le
conseil si je descendais la voir un jour
dans le dans le Var de marmer d'un
casque lourd car pour reprendre ses
paroles et bientôt les les les grenades
allaient pleuvoir exement ce qu'elle m'a
dit au téléphone aujourd'hui on est
évidemment
stubf vous la connaissiez Laurent Fabius
oui je la connaissais un petit peu parce
que nous étions collègues à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est une femme très très
souriante nous n'avons pas les mêmes
idées mais ça ne nous empêchait pas du
tout de de dialoguer je partage
l'indignation qui est ressentie ce soir
dans toute la France c'est vraiment que
que une femme une député soit assassiné
c'est quelque chose d'ignoble Philippe
de Viller a-t-il raison de dire que nous
sommes aujourd'hui l'Italie n sommes pas
l'Italie
mais on doit condamner avec une extrême
sévérité des gestes de ce type et moi je
souhaite que l'enquête soit rapide et
que les coupables soient châtiés et
soient châtiés sévèrement évidemment
vous n'avez aucune idée du mobile
possible aucune le 13 septembre dernier
le monde entier criait au miracles
croyait au miracle itraak Rabin et
Yasser Arafat se serrait la main à
Washington aujourd'hui cet espoir de
paix est compromis par la folie d'un
homme d'un Israélien qui a tué 52
Palestiniens le choc est encore
perceptible à Hébron où nos envoyés
spéciaux Olivier Lerner et lon grgo se
sont rendus ils en ont subi eux- mêmees
les conséquences mais sans gravité
la guerre des pierres a repris ses
droits dans les rues de Hébron pas un
magasin
ouverrouille les PAL sont sur les to
chez
généretrouvé son
visage lesrouilles sont ass également
par de jeunes colons à l'épaule la
mitraillette le Do sur la gâchette
qu'est-ce qui se passe depuis 24 he vous
faites des patrouilles qu'est-ce que
vous racontez là où allez-vous je r chez
moi patrouillez comme un soldat non peut
pas dire
ça le Tombeau des Patriarches est là
juste à côté gardé comme une forteresse
30 m plus loin une jeune femme
palestinenne fait entendre sa
voix ve
plusifre
terre
VI
et puis le chef d'étatmajor de l'armée
est arrivé l'enquête est en cours le
général Barac insiste sur un point un
seul homme en uniforme le colon de
kiratarba était à l'intérieur de la
mosquée mes soldats ont tiré en l'air
ditil ils étaient à l'extérieur le C des
patriarches situé juste derrière moi est
fermé au public jusqu'à nouvel ordre
juif et musulmans qui avaient l'habitude
de se retrouver ici pour prier ont été
conduits dans d'autres lieux de
recueillement en ville la tenenstion
n'est pas retombée pour autant l'armée
est omniprésente Hébron et ses environs
ont été placés sous couvre-feu et la
tension reste aussi forte dans les
autres territoires occupés par Israël
charlesenderlin Fadi Issaoui avait 21
ans il a été tué par un policier
israélien lors d'une manifestation
violente à isaoué un quartier
palestinien de Jérusalem bien qu'il
appartenait au Front démocratique une
organisation marxiste c'est aux
islamistes du Hamas que sa famille a
demandé de conduire les obsèques c'est
le ton aujourd'hui dans les territoires
occupés une heure plus tard c'est à
nouveau l'affrontement les jeunes
Palestiniens veulent en
découdre cette fois il n'y aura que des
blessés légers mais au cours des
accrochages de la journée trois
Palestiniens ont été tués la grève
générale décrétée par l'OLP a été
observée à 100% ces slogans signal Fatar
réclam une reprise de la lutte armée les
partisans du procè processus de paix ne
tiennent plus le haut du pavé et les
modérés Palestiniens et Israéliens
savent qu'ils n'ont que très peu de
temps pour désamorcer la crise partout
l'atmosphère se durcit en sjordanie à
Gaza à Jérusalem Est mais aussi et c'est
grave dans les localités arabe
israélienne ces images ont été tournées
à Jafa le quartier arabe de
téavivelem en Galilé le mouvement
islamiste organiser une véritable
démonstration de force le gouvernement
israélien se réunit demain matin pour
décider des mesures
François mitan a écrit à Rabin et à
Yasser Arafat Bill Clinton les a invité
à nouveau à se rendre à Washington mais
il ne se fait gure d'illusion pour
l'instant Yass Arafat préfère attendre
et voir il l'a dit à notre envoyé
spécial à Tunis Michel
monp nous avons besoin maintenant d'une
protection internationale pour notre
peuple c'est
primordial il y a un paragraphe dans
l'accord de paix que nous avons signé en
septembre dernier à Washington qui
mentionne une présence
internationale et les Israéliens l'ont
accepté les colons armé sont une vraie
bombe à
retardement nous demandons que le
gouvernement israélien prenne des
mesures qu'il agisse et qu'il assume ses
responsabilités qu'il fasse ce qu'il a
signé
Clint il est vrai que le président
Clinton nous a lancé une invitation à
négocier mais avant d'y aller nous
voulons savoir quelle est la nouvelle
donne les démocrates russes craignent un
nouveau coup d'État dans leur pays
craintte fondé sur la libération des
hommes qui avaient tenté de renverser
Boris yelsin libération décidée par le
Parlement conservateur contre la vie du
président russe ainsi Alexandre rutkoy
qui avait tenu la vedette lors de la
dernière tentative de PCH va pouvoir à
nouveau tenir la vedette Dominique der
et George Hansen qui était bien
renseigné l'attendait chez
lui le maître est de retour et Aaron
chien fidèle ne s'y est pas trompé c'est
bien lui qui revient dans son costume de
général avec toutes ses médailles et 12
kil de monde Alexandre Ruty l'un des
meneurs avec rasbouatov de la sanglante
rébellion parlementaire en octobre
dernier emprisonné pendant 153 jours
amnistié mercredi par le nouveau
Parlement libéré cet après-midi jadis
cet ancien Afghanistan fut l'allié de
yelsin son vice-président même avant de
devenir son plus farouche adversaire
Rima la servante a mis sur la table
familiale ce que préfère monsieur depuis
hier elle ne quitte plus sa cuisine je
pensait dit-elle qu'ils allaient le
relâcher plus vite lou Mila son épouse
nous l'avons rencontré la veille elle
venait de lu apporter en prison son
uniforme elle le voyait une fois par
mois depuis sa rédition
il espère que le temps et l'histoire
tranch il pense que la loi
l'emportera que l'on rétablira la vérité
sur ce qui s'est
passé il ne se considère pas totalement
coupable c'est aussi mon
avis lae de la
prison président désormais bauis Helsin
sait qu'il lui faudra à nouveau
affronter un adversaire qu'il avait cru
pour longtemps écartter de l'arèine
politique en France le Parti socialiste
réfléchit sur la meilleure manière de
lutter contre le chômage faut-il ou non
réduire tout de suite la durée du
travail la question semble diviser les
socialistes avant d'écouter notre invité
Laurent Fabius suivons nos envoyés
spéciaux Roland SICAR et Luc bachofhen à
cette convention du PS sur
l'emploi au PS il y a une règle d'or les
progrès se font pas à pas et une marche
après l'autre c'est peut-être cette
prudence qui explique que Michel rckard
retrouve peu à peu le sourire avant de
reparler de l'emploi il a attendu
presque un an et comme en ce moment il a
plutôt de la chance l'affaire de ce que
certains ont appelé le SMIC jeune est
venu mettre tout à coup ses amis
d'accord c'est un SMIC au Rabet je veux
dire quand on pense que qu'un jeune de
24 ans qui a un bac plus 2 pourra être
payé 3700 francs net pendant 2 ans c'est
vraiment la création d'un SMIC que rien
ne justifie c'est un scandale absolu et
à vrai dire c'est bien la méthode
baladure on ne dit pas ce qu'on fait et
on fait ce qu'on ne dit pas seulement
pour le reste le PS a plus de mal à
trouver un accord comment avancer sur la
question du chômage 35h tout de suite
37h 32h avec ou sans baisse des salaires
rien n'est tranché simplement beaucoup
trouvent que dans cette affaire la
direction du parti manque
d'audace je pense que les socialistes au
fond savent parfaitement que le
libéralisme économique mène les salariés
à l'échec c'est-à-dire à la diminution
de leur pouvoir
d'achat à la disparition de leur système
de protection sociale mais qui n'osent
pas le dire et je pense que le moment
est venu de le dire et de le dire avec
une certaine force parce que la
politique c'est un rapport de force et
c'est là que s'ouvre le véritable débat
le PS doit-il prendre des positions
radicales comme la semaine de 35h tout
de suite au risque de perdre son image
de parti de gouvernement au contraire
doit-il garder des positions plus
mesurées au risque cette fois de ne pas
toucher les dividendes de retour dans
l'opposition entre les deux le choix est
difficile beaucoup pronostiquent
d'ailleurs pour demain une solution de
compromis alors Rolin SCA a bien posé la
question c'est le problème de fond si
j'ai bien suivi ce qu'il nous a dit vous
êtes d'accord vous les socialistes dans
l'opposition édard Baladur par exemple
sur le smiction mais pas encore dans la
proposition revenons à la question de
fond la question de fond c'est celle
qu'on vit tous les jours c'est-à-dire
une dégradation de l'emploi qui continue
non pas du tout que nous ayons réussi
nous quand nous étions au gouvernement
il faut être très
humble oui ni la gauche ni la droite
n'ont réussi c'est clair d'où humilité
mais aussi imagination alors la question
c'est comment arrêter cette dégradation
et créer des emplois c'est là où et je
dis d'abord arrêter cette dégradation
parce que moi je vois sur le terrain
tous les jours des usines qui tombent
des entreprises qui ferment des
commerces qui ferment et et c'est une
véritable hémorragie donc il y a d'abord
ça à faire et à protéger les salariés
c'est là où où où la question du SMIC
jeune est très importante ce qu'on a vu
les réactions qui ont été celle de des
interviewés sont justes mais il faut
aller de l'avant et et moi je vais
prendre une initiative allez la semaine
prochaine je déposerai une proposition
de loi de défense du SMIC et de refus de
toute discrimination en direction des
jeunes cette proposition comportera deux
articles premier article à travail égal
on n' pas le droit de souspayer un jeune
parce qu'il est jeune deè article toutes
les dispositions contraires sont
supprimées et je demanderai au Premier
ministre l'inscription d'urgence à
l'ordre du jour vous devriez être
rassuré parce qu'en haut Loire hier le
Premier ministre a dit il est hors de
question d'adopter ce smiction c'est
pourtant ce que fait un décret qui vient
d'être publié je ne fais pas de procès
d'intention au Premier ministre mais si
ce qu'il dit est vrai alors ma
proposition de loi sera votée et vous
pensez qu'elle le sera oui mais ça
voudrait dire l'annulation du décret
parce que entrons un instant dans les
détails ça concerne quand même des
millions de gens
ce décret prévoit que si vous êtes jeune
et si vous faites le travail que fait un
adulte vous ne touchez que 80 % du SM
c'est 3800 francs contrat d'insertion
professionnelle non non non oui ça
s'appelle contrat d'insertion
professionnelle en réalité c'est un
contrat d'exploitation des jeunes
mettez-vous à la place d'un chef
d'entreprise s'il peut avoir un jeune
qui ne coûte entre guillemets que 3800
francs pour faire le travail de
quelqu'un d'autre ce quelqu'un d'autre
il va le renvoyer il va prendre le jeûne
pendant 2 ans puisqu'on a le droit à 2
ans et au bout de 2 ans le jeûne lui
même sera renvoyé pour quelqu'un d'autre
qui ne coûtera que 80 % du SM donc ça
veut dire que je dépose la semaine
prochaine cette proposition de loi ou
bien elle est inscrite et voter et donc
le décret supprimant le SMIC lui-même
est annulé ou bien le gouvernement ne
veut pas inscrire cette propositionors
du jour il a voté et à ce moment-là une
grande campagne commence dans l'opinion
parce que nous nous refusons que l'on
soupaye les jeunes c'est clair bon alors
j'imagine que vous aurez tous les
socialistes derrière vous sur cette
proposition seulement les socialistes
avez dit tout à l'heure imagination oui
alors ça c'est la création d'emploi
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous lancez
comme idée nouvell à supposer qu'un jour
vous reveniez au pouvoir merci pour le à
supposer il faut il faut poser la
question de l'emploi au cœur de la
démarche et là je dis imagination et
j'énumère parce qu'on a que le temps
d'énumérer au moins quatre pistes
première piste relancer ce qui crée de
l'emploi en France et je pense en
particulier au logement on nous dit tous
les jours c'est annoncé on fait les
choses en matière de logement et Cera
c'est pas vrai il y a des dizaines de
milliers de gens qui n'attendent que la
création d'un logement à condition que
les taux d'intérêt le permettre bon là
on peut créer des dizaines de milliers
d'emplois deuxièmement tout ce qu'on
appelle les emplois de proximité si on
parle des besoins les besoins pour les
personnes les besoins pour les jeunes
les besoins pour la sécurité il y a
aussi des centaines de milliers
d'emplois à créer troisièmement je pense
qu'il faut pour les emplois non
qualifiés abaisser les charges parce que
les charges sont trop lourdes pour les
entreprises et quatrièmement c'est le
débat qu'on vient de voir une certaine
réduction de la du travail il y a un
mouvement historique de réduction du
travail depuis des dizaines d'années il
va se continuer mais il n'est pas
question avec réduction de des salaires
non il est pas question pour quelqu'un
gagne 6000 francs 8000 francs 10000
francs de lui dire on va vous baisser
votre temps de travail et vous baisser
votre salaire il ne marchera pas il aura
raison donc il faut une réduction
progressive et en même temps une
certaine redistribution générale des
revenus et en particulier des revenus du
capital Laurent Fabius vous avez été
ministre puis Premier ministre est-ce
que aujourd'hui vous êtes dans
l'opposition est-ce que c'est pas plus
facile d'imaginer quand on est dans
l'opposition quand on est au pouvoir
oui et on peut nous faire ce reproche ou
tout au moins cette interrogation dire
mais pourquoi navezv pas fa j'accepte
tout à fait ce reproche mais ce que je
constate aujourd'hui c'est que la
précarité grandit le chômage grandit et
qu'on va aller je vous préviens vers des
explosions sociales toute la politique
devrait être centrée uniquement sur
l'emploi on a un système fiscal qui a
été bâti à un moment où le chômage
n'existait pas système social la même
chose c'est il faut mettre ça au cœur de
notre démarche c'est-à-dire que quand on
parle à un homme politique quand l'homme
politique répond
quels que soient les sujets politiqu
extérieur politique intérieure il ne
devrait avoir qu'une idée en tête
qu'est-ce qui peut défendre et créer
l'emploi moi c'est ainsi maintenant que
je vais faire est-ce que ça veut dire
qu'à vos yeux l'élection présidentielle
l'année prochaine se fera sur ce thème
oui je souhaite qu'elle se fasse sur ce
thème parce que finalement c'est le
thème décisif on parlait tout à l'heure
de la drogue on parle des quartiers on
parle de la violence urbaine de la
sécurité on parle des jeunes tout ce qui
ce qui est décisif c'est la création
d'emploi donc il n'y a que ça finalement
d'important et je souhaite que la
principale question qu'on pose c'est
qu'est-ce que vous avez à proposer pour
l'emploi je travaille avec les
socialistes on avance une dernière
question ce sera la seule question
politique moi je ne dis pas politicienne
qui devra représenter le et représenter
le PS à l'élection présidentielle on
verra pour le moment bon pour le moment
c'est Michel rard qui est comme on
ditand naturel mais on n'est pas encore
en situation on décidera à la fin de
l'année début de l'année prochaine merci
Laur Fabius mais quel qu'il soit il
devra mettre l'emploi non seulement au
cœur de sa campagne mais ça devrait être
le sujet ex exusif de sa campagne vous
avez dit quel qu'il soit en ce qui vous
concerne vous l'excluez ou pas je sois
en situation mais en tout cas j'aiderai
beaucoup celui qui le sera merci Laurent
Fabius hier dans ce même journal je vous
annonca une prise d'otage à la mairie de
perrepignan finalement tout s'est bien
passé l'homme qui retenait le directeur
de cabinet du maire de la ville s'est
rendu il s'agit de l'oncle de la petite
Karine qui avait été violé et assassiné
il exigeait qu'on lui livre l'auteur du
crime les voleurs d'or n'ont pas eu le
temps d'apprécier leur butin 8 millions
de francs de bijou dévalisés à Saumur
dans le manéloir à peine arrivé le
lendemain dans son repère la région
liyonnaise le gang s'est fait cueillir
par les policiers reportage de Françoise
valet et Philippe Fivet des pendentifs
des bagues des colliers et autres bijoux
il y a là 60000 pièces en or un butin
estimé à 8 millions de francs les
malfaiteurs avaient bien calculé leur
coût après l'attaque à main armée d'une
fabrique de bijoux près de sa mur
mercredi soir ils prennent la route
direction le sud ce qu'il ne savaiit pas
c'est qu'à Saint-Étienne les policiers
les attendaient en tout 25 personnes ont
été interpellées les perquisitions ont
été fructueuses 280 g de cocaïne pure
une vingtaine d'armes 500000 francs en
liquide manifestement le gang n'en était
pas à son premier coup depuis 6 mois
nous étions derrière les membres de
cette équipe là pour nous attacher à à
déterminer quel était exactement leur
style de leur style d'exaction euh les
prises démontrent que c'était voilà m
armée vraisemblablement raquett trafic
des de cocaïne enfin vous voyez ce que
je dirais le haut de gamme du banditisme
basé à Lyon le commando agissait sur
tout le territoire à leur tête Patrick
Robert 33 ans bien connu des services de
police déjà arrêté en 84 il opérait dans
le Gang des grandes oreilles une bande
de l'ouest lyonnais spécialisée dans
l'attaque de banque à main armée 8
années de réclusion ne l'ont pas calmé
lui et ses complices menaient la belle
vie six d'entre eux ont été arrêtés à
Cannes à deux pas de la Croisette placés
en garde à vu ils seront déférés demain
au parquet de
Lyon les chasseurs dans la ville mais
sans leur fusil les amateurs de palombe
de canard et de tourterelles se sont
rassemblés nombreux à Bordeaux pour
protester contre les restrictions
imposées par l'Europe les palombes VT
évité aujourd'hui Bordeaux Gill Marinet
Anne fribau 60000 chasseurs au moins
dans les rues de Bordeaux un véritable
rat demaré ils sont venus de tout le
Sud-Ouest et même du Midi de la France
pour protester contre les directives
européennes qui veulent restreindre la
chasse aux oiseaux migrateurs nous nous
doutions monsieur que les chasseurs de
Laquitaine n'allaient pas rester comme
ça se faire matraquer sans bouger ça
c'est clair et aujourd'hui il viennent
d'apporter un message on ne touche pas
aux chasses traditionnelles c'est le
message à destination du ministre de
l'Environnement et du Parlement européen
mais cette marée humaine est venue aussi
clamer l'inquiétude d'un monde rural qui
se sent délaissé voire méprisé c'est
notre patrimoine la chasse et on
n'autorise aucun politique ni qui que ce
soit à parler de ces chosesl ce sont les
chasseurs qui doivent gérer en paère de
famille en gestionnaire leur patrimoine
je suis étudiant donc je pense avoir des
capacités intellectuelles normales et je
crois qu'on en a marre de ce de qu'on
nous prenne pour des pour des des
pariades défendre la chasse pour mieux
défendre la campagne un amalgam qui
aujourd'hui a fait recette actuellement
ce qu'on est en train de faire avec les
directives européennes c'est de
déménager le monde rural on le vide de
son agriculture on le vide de ses
loisirs en le vidant de la chasse demain
de la pêche on le vide et nous on veut
le défendre on ve vivre dans le monde
rural ils étai des dizaines de milliers
une démonstration de force réussie et
quiid dans certaines régions va peser
lourd au moment des élections
cantonales de la ferme à la table fois
gras poulet magré de canard fromage miel
vin olive huile d'olive Rome c'est la
plus belle façon de vous présenter le
salon de l'agriculture qui s'ouvrira
demain vous allez encore davantage
saliver en regardant les images de
jean-if Perin et Philippe montoisi tous
ces produits de la Grande Bouffe ont été
primés pour être juré au concours
général agricole même avec la chemise
appropriée il vaut mie avoir le cœur
bien accroché à cette table par exemple
il juge des huiles d'olive dès 9h du
matin il leur faut renifler goûter
avaler une bonne dizaine d'échantillons
tout anonyme un sport réservé au
professionnels généralement des
producteurs et à quelques amateurs
éclairés l'huile n'est pas une boisson
c'est un aliment donc on le goûte comme
un aliment et surtout ne pas avoir
d'huile avec des défauts qui sentent qui
sentent des odeurs qui sont pas très
agréables dans l'assiette comme une
odeur de peinture ou une odeur de rance
l'épreuve met en jeu tous lesessens par
exemple pour les fois gras il faut avoir
plutôt du nez par contre on ne goûte pas
les volailles elles sont jugé à l'œil et
au
doigt des dizaines de produits venus de
toute la France sont évalués comme cela
une fois par an mais au fait ça sert à
quoi tout ça à travers le système actuel
qui nous a amené à des problèmes
vis-à-vis du Gat vis-à-vis de la Pâque
et la banalisation des produits le
concours valorise les produit avec une
médaille on arrive à mieux vendre on
arrive aussi à vendre des fois plus cher
et oui ici aussi la récompense c'est une
médaille or argent bronze comme aux Jeux
olympiques mais avec le concours
agricole ça marche à tous les coups sur
6000 produits présentés 2000 sont
médaillés le jour où nos sportifs font
aussi bien que nos nos paysans les
médailles pleuverront ne soyons pas trop
sévères la France a récolté une nouvelle
médaille de bronze dans le relais homme
biathlon Thierry
clopo tout se joue ici sur le dernier
relais la dernière position du tir
debout le Biélorusse repart en tête
Hervé Flandin le français lui manque une
cible et se lance à la poursuite de
Popof avec 16 secondes de retard il
reste alors 2,m5 à courir c'est la
glisse qui va faire la différence et
dans une montée Flandin clou sur place
le biélorusse
du B salin et Laurent ses équipiers n'en
croi pas leurs yeux Flandin le douanier
de Modane va-t-il résister jusquau
bout cette foisci les dieux de l'Olympe
sont avec la France et pour la première
fois de son histoire le relais français
de biathlon décroche une médaille
olympique c'est vrai ce n'est que du
Bronze Maisel r tellement heureux les
copains
d'abord c'est fabuleux c'est ma première
médaille tous les copains étai déjà
médaill en rel du monde ou en course par
équipe moi ça fait 3 ans que je suis
leader de l'équipe j'avais jamais une
médaille je pensais tellement les faire
en individuel que là se rela il me
l'offre [__] les copains c'est
super heureusement qu'ils étaient au
rendez-vous nos biathlètes avec trois
médailles l'argent pour brillant le
bronze pour le relais féminin et de
nouveau le bronze ce matin pour les
garçons c'est 60 % du total olympique
français qu'il lu cru en France il n'y a
que 200 licenciés et en l'espace de
trois courses grâce à une bande de
copains et de copines et un entraîneur
hor paère ce sport d'iver s'est fait une
place au soleil
chapeau faut-il ou non revenir sur
l'échec de Suria Bonali hier non sinon
pour rappeler la médaille d'audience
recueillie par France 2 18 million de
téléspectateurs beaucoup plus nombreux
que lors de la première épreuve et puis
l'avenir de suourria est toujours devant
elle il a même recommencé aujourd'hui à
l'occasion du galat d'exhibition à l'
Hameur elle a de nouveau patiné avec les
meilleurs morceaux choisis par Frédéric
bet et an Claude Becket regardons
simplement sans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parler
[Musique]
N
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
P
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
to see you inano in
1998 thank you c'était magnifique et
c'était retransmis aujourd'hui par
France 2 à 15h30 j'espère qu'on pourra
en faire une vidéo le cinéma est en fait
ce soir la grande famille du grand écran
s'est réunie pour la distribution des
prix cérémonie qui a été retransmise par
Canal plus à 19h qui a reçu le César 94
du meilleur réalisateur réponse donc les
six nommés pour le meilleur réalisateur
sont Claude Berry pour
Germinal
Bertrand Blier pour 1 2 3
soleil Christophe kieslovski pour
bleu Jean-Marie Poiré pour les
visiteurs Alain Renet pour smoking no
smoking chin pour ma saison
préférée je vais dire que c'est assez
grisant d'avoir l'attention de si grand
mteur en scène sur
soi même si c'est pas pour moi mais je
vais pas faire durer mon
plaisir le César est attribué à Alain
Renet pour smoking no
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
smoking
[Applaudissements]
quelle souffrance pour ceux qui espèrent
l'avoir et qui ne l'ont pas nous allons
maintenant rejoindre Éric Périn en
direct du Théâtre des Champs-Élysées
alors avez-vous d'autres César à nous
communiquer la souffrance n'est pas tout
à fait terminée pour tout le monde
puisqu'on attend les résultats en ce qui
concerne le César du meilleur acteur et
du meilleur film la cérémonie a Priss un
petit peu de retard donc je ne sais pas
si nous aurons le temps de vous
communiquer les résultats dans le
journal mais il y a quelqu'un pour qui
la souffrance est terminée c'est pour la
meilleure actrice alors je vous propose
peut-être de voir les image que nous
avons dû caler et le César de la
meilleure actrice a été àrive à Juliette
Binoche voilà j'ai devancé un petit peu
Juliette Binoche pour son interprétation
dans bleu de Christophe kiselovski déjà
récompensé d'ailleurs à Venise nommé
également pour aux États-Unis Juliette
Binoche que tout le monde dont tout le
monde a souligné l'interprétation
magique al dans bleu alors je vous
propose si jamais pour le meilleur
acteur et pour le meilleur film les
résultats arrivent avant la fin de ce
journal de vous appeler à ce momentlà
Paul mais ce journal est terminé Eric
donc é vous les donnera 23h alors non
mais je veux pas vous faire souffrir
vous et puis moimême j'ai pas du tout
envie de souffrir donc notre notre chef
d'édition va nous demander si on peut
garder ou non l'antenne pour attendre la
nomination non non faut rendre l'antenne
parce que le programme est très riche ce
soir alors er vous donnz des
informations ce soir dans le dernier
journal suivez cettemiss mission pour
nous à tout à l'heure à tout à l'heure
voilà donc le journal est terminé on
saura tout à l'heure qui remportera le
César du meilleur acteur ou du meilleur
film d'ailleurs sachez que demain nous
parlerons aussi cinéma avec notre invité
roman borenger qui réapparaît dans un
film qui s'appelle Mina nous la
recevrons demain en direct dans ce
journal qui est terminé ce soir dans
quelques instants Nathalie ri je g canal
plus bon vous pouvez tout à l'heure
zapper sur Canal Plus pour savoir mais
quelques minutes à peine pour savoir qui
recevra le César du meilleur acteur
c'est pas du tout le moment donc
Nathalie riweet vous parlera du temps
dans un instant et du retour de la pluie
20h50 Frédéric mitteran recevra la
grande petite Mimi mati 22h40 Sylvie
Vartan dans Taratata le dernier journal
à min 10 avec Philippe lefet et je vous
retrouverai demain à 13h après l'heure
de vérité à la Madelin sera l'invité
bonne soirée sur France 2 avec Mimi
bonsoir